[Musique]
m
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlogs
l'isolent de la société
le new york times
le washington post
der spiegel
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçus
mais pas surpris
[Musique]
on
21h30 pour décrypter les grands titres
de l'actualité de la journée au sommaire
de ce mercredi 26 janvier décryptage des
tout derniers développements dans la
crise ukrainienne l'otan entend à
nouveau la main la russie mais se
prépare au pire l'otan et ans tentera de
répondre aux exigences de la russie tout
comme les états unis l'ont fait dans le
même temps une réponse qui offrirait une
voie diplomatique sérieuse si la russie
le souhaite selon anthony blinken les
etats unis qui disait un peu plus tôt
s'attendre à une agression russe dans
les trois prochaines semaines alors que
des représentants russes ukrainiens
allemands et français se réunissent en
ce moment au format normandie à paris
alors que le patron de l'otan est en
train d'achever sa conférence de presse
pour parler de ces derniers
développements dans la crise ukrainienne
l'étau se resserre autour de boris
johnson le premier ministre britannique
s'est une nouvelle fois défendu bec et
ongles aujourd'hui face aux critiques de
l'opposition
sa place de premier ministre est
désormais suspendu à la publication d'un
rapport interne potentiellement explosif
sur les fêtes tenu à downing street
pendant les confinements une enquête a
aussi été ouverte par la police
britannique pour savoir si la loi était
emprunt en mai 2020 décryptage avec
claude blanchemaison dans quelques
minutes
le liban tente toujours de sortir de la
crise économique le pays souffre
notamment d'un problème de production de
courant électrique
aujourd'hui deux pays a signé un accord
de raccordement avec la jordanie un
acheminement d'électricité via la syrie
voisine ou pour fournir 10% des besoins
du pays de quoi assurer deux heures
d'électricité supplémentaires par jour
analyse également dans cette émission
depuis le début de l'année un français
sur dix a été testé positif au co vidé
hier un nouveau cap a été franchi plus
d'un demi million de cas de
contamination recensé un record des
chiffres également en hausse à l'hôpital
où plus de 30 mille patients sont
hospitalisés
le nombre quotidien de contamination aux
variants mikron continue de grimper
alors que le pass vaccinale est entrée
en application il ya deux jours un
véritable casse tête pour les
restaurateurs notamment dans notre
rubrique en pensent les français nous
irons à la rencontre de l'un d'entre eux
à paris qui aujourd'hui se dit prêt à
baisser les bras reportage à suivre dès
21h
[Musique]
beaucoup de développement ce soir en ce
moment même dans la crise ukrainienne
tout s'accélère l'otan est en train de
tenir une conférence de presse pour
rendre une réponse officielle à moscou
même chose du côté des états unis on en
parle avec notre reporter guillemin
rossi bonsoir guillemin quelles sont les
informations que vous détenez on sait
que washington refuse d'exclure une
adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan yum un
oui bonsoir stéphanie oui c'est tout à
fait cela les etats unis ont refusé
d'accéder aux exigences de la russie sur
le nom élargissement de l'otan et
l'intégration et la non-intégration de
l'ukraine ainsi que sur le retrait des
troupes de l'alliance atlantique
d'europe de l'est c'est ce que demande
moscou depuis des mois maintenant et qui
semble être un prérequis à toute avancée
sur sa crise ukrainienne et puis il y a
eu d'autres source de nouvelles tensions
vous en avez rapidement parler la vice
secrétaire d'état américaine wendy
sherman qui a déclaré aujourd'hui que
tout indiqué je cite que la russie
allait faire usage de la force
probablement d'ici trois semaines et
l'ambassade américaine à kiev a exhorté
ses ressortissants à quitter le pays
parallèlement six avions de combat
américains sont arrivés aujourd'hui en
estonie pour renforcer renforcer la
mission de l'otan dans ce pays je le
rappelle frontaliers de la russie et
c'est sans compter sans ses 4000 obus
d'artillerie que va envoyer à kiev la
république tchèque
des éléments donc inquiétant la porte
des négociations et elles totalement
fermées à l'heure où l'on parle en
alors peut-être pas totalement encore
stéphanie parce que d'un autre côté vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure anthony
blinken a déclaré qu'il était disposé à
rencontrer son homologue russe sergueï
lavrov et qu'il offrait je cite une voie
diplomatique sérieuse si la russie le
désirez et c'est sans compter les
européens l'europe qui veut elle
continuait à négocier preuve en est
cette réunion aujourd'hui à l'elysée au
format normandie c'est à dire entre
russes et ukrainiens à mêmes allemands
et français pardon pour discuter du
dombass réunion qui s'est terminée il y
avait il ya peu après huit heures de
négociations on espère que cela augure
des avancées diplomatiques un merci
guillemard aussi de ces précisions et de
son côté le ministère russe des affaires
étrangères vient d'annoncer que
l'ambassadeur américain en russie lui
avait remis donc cette réponse de
washington aux exigences russes un de
retrait de l'otan d'europe orientale
dans le cadre de cette crise on retrouve
notre correspondante maëlys destrée à
moscou bonsoir maëlys quelles sont les
informations dont vous disposez
bonsoir stéphanie le vice ministre russe
des affaires étrangères a en effet reçu
l'ambassadeur américain à moscou à la
demande de ce dernier d'après un
communiqué de la diplomatie russe
l'ambassadeur américain remis la réponse
écrite de washington au projet de traité
bilatéral sur les garanties de sécurité
présenté précédemment par la partie
russe
et on a appris que donc l'otan avait
également remis sa réponse à la russie
donc avait menacé moscou de sanctions en
cas d'invasion l'ukraine visant
personnellement vladimir poutine le chef
de la diplomatie russe lui a répondu ce
matin
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères a reproché aux états unis de
tenter de punir la russie avec des
sanctions de pousser kiev a dirigé des
provocations contre moscou d'après le
chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov l'occident adopte une politique
de deux poids deux mesures à l'égard de
la crise ukrainienne il a appelé encore
une fois au respect des accords du bhns
est coûteux mais l'occident ne devait
pas se calmer et il veut pas que le
crâne se calme l'occident
je vraiment une provocation réel tout ça
pour moi
manifestement
va dans le sens
d'un site et le régime de kiev a
commencé une opération de force à dubaï
ou par un autre moyen faire un terrain
complètement les accords de minsk
nonobstant les incantations 2002 berland
de paris de washington
qui ne cesse pas de dire que les recours
de minsk et reste une fois sans
alternative pour la régulation du
conflit le kremlin a également réagi à
cette menace de sanctions d'après son
porte parole dmitri peskov celle ci ne
serait pas je suis douloureuse mais
seraient nocives sur le plan politique
les membres du congrès et les sénateurs
américains qui ne connaissent pas tout à
fait ce sujet évoque le gel des actifs
des représentants des autorités russes
des comptes bancaires des biens
mobiliers des biens immobiliers et
cetera mais cela apparemment est liée au
fait qu'ils n'ont pas une expertise
suffisante et il ne demande pas de la
fournir à ceux qui s'occupent
professionnellement de la russie
le fait est que conformément à notre loi
c'est une interdiction de longue date
aux représentants de la haute direction
et aux fonctionnaires
par conséquent bien sûr une telle
formulation de la question n'est
absolument pas douloureuse pour requins
des représentants de la haute direction
reste maintenant à voir si les réponses
des états unis et de l'otan permettront
d'atténuer le climat de tension actuelle
d'après sergueï lavrov de nouvelles
propositions russes devraient
prochainement rédigé en fonction de ces
réponses puis soumises avait des mires
poutine merci mme élise d'estrées en
direct de moscou alors comment
comprendre les derniers développements a
notamment la réponse de l'otan dont on
parlait mais la réponse américaine
également à la russie est ce une vraie
chance de désescalade quelle marge de
manoeuvre pour le format normandie qui
se tient en ce moment tout de suite
c'est l'heure de notre décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau général dominique trinquant
expert en géostratégie bonsoir général
merci d'être avec nous à nos côtés
également on dirait que vous aviez
moreau directeur de strates paul alors
on le disait un monsieur beaucoup de
développement ce soir conférence de
presse en ce moment même de l'otan les
états unis surtout qu'ils viennent de
refuser un d'exclure une adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'otan comme le demande la
russie s'étaient cette fameuse ligne
rouge dont on parle souvent en ce moment
mais offert je cite ce qu'il juge une
voie diplomatique sérieuse pour sortir
de la crise dans leurs réponses écrites
aux demandes de moscou voici ce qu'on
apprend ce soir xavier moreau à partir
du moment où la ligne rouge fixée par
moscou n'est pas respectée est-ce qu'on
peut décemment vraiment envisagé cette
voie sérieuse dont parle anthony blinken
ce soir oui parce qu'on fait il y à il
ya deux choses différentes il voulait il
ya d'un côté ce besoin de rapprochements
qui vient des états unis de renouer la
relation une relation normale avec la
russie donc qui a culminé en juin
dernier avec la rencontre entre poutine
et baden à moscou et donc on est
toujours dans ce cycle de négociations
et vous avez d'un autre côté une crise
complètement artificielle qui a été
monté par kiev et des occidentaux qui
ressemble un peu à rené moi ou je fais
un malheur et qui va mon avis éteindre
d'ici un mois avant peut-être de
repartir dans de trois mois ce qu'on
nous jouons en ukraine aujourd'hui c'est
exactement ce qu'on nous a joué au
printemps dernier
par ailleurs nous annonçait que la
russie allait envahir envers l'ukraine
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut pas
lier ces deux choses vous avez d'une
part un rapprochement qui malgré tout
continuent à fonctionner puisque on ne
sait exactement parce qu'il ya dans la
lettre qu'a envoyée
ce cas qu'à amener sullivan donc
l'ambassadeur des etats-unis à moscou au
ministère dès à présent les américaines
dont vous avez ça et ça ça ça continue
donc évidemment que les américains ne
vont pas dire oui surtout dans dans ce
domaine là de toute manière le cren en
l'état ne peut pas rentrer dans le temps
puisque elle revendique une partie d'un
territoire qui est aujourd'hui détenue
par russie qui impliquait la crimée donc
ça voudrait dire que tous les membres de
l'otan sera automatiquement en guerre si
la
cie le crès de rejoignait la crimée
c'est rejoignez par exemple l'otan
exactement comme pour la géorgie
puisqu'il ya des bases et russe en
abkhazie et en ossétie du sud donc vous
avez donc d'un côté cette relation entre
les etats-unis et la russie qui continue
et d'ailleurs anthony blinken a dit que
l'année la semaine prochaine il
parlerait à son homologue on part de la
mise en place d'un nouveau sommet entre
eux entre washington et moscou et puis
vous avez ce psychodrame qu'on est en
train de nous jouer autour de l'ukraine
et si vous aviez vous avez écouté
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs l'information en
ukraine le secrétaire général du conseil
de sécurité créé lundi qu'il n'y a pas
de risque à l'invasion imminente de la
russie ça a été repris également par le
ministère de la défense donc je pense
qu'il va il va falloir raison garder
redescendre un petit peu en pression et
voir que finalement le mouvement actuel
n'est pas si négatif général traquant
vous avez le même diagnostic assez
optimiste de xavier moreau parce que ce
soir ce qui se passe c'est quand même
important alors aurier a peut-être pas
de surprise enfin les choses se dénouent
il ya des réponses officielles et c'est
un petit peu une fin de non recevoir à
ce qu'exigeait tout de même la russie en
termes de lignes rouges est ce que c'est
inquiétant oui moi là où je suis assez
surpris c'est pas du tout sûr la réponse
américaine et de l'otan c'est sur la
question posée par les russes comment
ont-ils pu imaginer un seul instant que
le temps allait accepter qu'elle ne
laisse pas les portes ouvertes et
qu'elles retirent des troupes de pays
qui ont librement accepté de participer
à l'otan c'est ça qui me gêne donc si
vous voulez
le fait que l'otan par le biais des
américains disent non aujourd'hui c'est
une réponse normale et ce qui me gêne un
petit peu c'est dans quelle position
c'est monsieur poutine parce que quand
vous mettez sur la table ddd des
positions dont vous savez que celui à
qui vous les présentez répondra non vous
mettez quand même un peu dans un coin ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
c'est dans la réponse américaine ce que
je trouve intéressant c'est qu'on en
revient à des vrais sujets au problème
des missiles nucléaires
européens de moyenne portée et au
contrôle
les accords fce vous souvenez qu'il y
avait désaccord fce qui faisait que par
exemple les manoeuvres qui se passe
actuellement russe en ukraine à côté de
l'ukraine pardon aurait dû avoir une
déclaration préalable et des inspections
de même que des mouvements de le temps
aurait dû avoir des déclarations
préalables et des inspections et puis la
fameuse les fameux accords de ciel
ouvert alors qu'on en revienne à ces
choses là pour ça très intéressant parce
que ça éviterait les conflits un peu
d'aveuglés qu'on a actuellement où
n'importe qui peut raconter n'importe
quoi sans qu'ils aient vraiment de
vérification je vous propose justement
d'écouter ce total ben justement sur ces
conditions d'adhésion à l'otan
lorsqu'un pays décide de poser sa
candidature pour une adhésion à l'otan
nous le respectons c'est le cas de
l'ukraine pareil lorsqu'un pays décide
de ne pas se porter candidat comme c'est
le cas de la finlande et de la suède par
exemple il s'agit de respecter le roi le
droit à
l'autodétermination même si les
décisions liées à l'adhésion ans doivent
se faire par qu'elle s'en suit le fait
d'être en bio très bien entendu avec
même le pays qui fait très peu demande
d'adhésion
c'est en principe un de nos principes
fondamentaux nous c'est bien entendu
répéter dans les positions de l'otan
xavier moreau astronautes berquier un
petit peu sans la même ligne que le gène
à trak ans sur ce plateau c'est
peut-être vite oublié les promesses au
lendemain de la chute
du mur de berlin alors c'est vrai que le
général me disait c'était pas la même
période mais mais tout de même
et j'ai nommé déjà le stoltenberg entre
guillemets on lui a rien demandé les
questions elles ont pas été donné à
l'otan avec laquelle la russie pense
qu'il est il est désormais inutile de
parler comme avec les pays européens
mais aux états unis et d'ailleurs ce qui
est intéressant dans cet aspect c'est
que blinken pour rassurer les donc les
membres de l'otan avait fait faire on
fait une lettre parallèlement aux à
l'otan mais encore une fois commenté ce
que dit blinken des gens ne sais pas ce
qu'il ya dans cette réponse et la demie
et les diplomates américains monde est
ce que les russes ne les publient pas on
verra si les russes vont accepter ou pas
mais le fait est que on peut commenter
effectivement ce que ce que dit blinken
mais commenter ce que dit parlons ce que
dit stoltenberg mais sollten de la
russie ne lui a rien demandé encore une
fois la russie a fermé sa représentation
diplomatique
à l'otan et a fait fermer la
représentation de l'otan en russie parce
que justement c'est à une structure avec
laquelle il est impossible de parler et
donc la politique de la demi-heure
poutine et c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
voir l'importance de ces relations en
direct
c'est de recréer un lien direct avec
washington pour arriver éviter de perdre
son temps avec justement l'otan alors je
suis très content que stoltenberg et
donner son avis et je comprends pourquoi
blinken l'ami l'amitié dans la boucle
mais en soit les russes n'attendais rien
de spécial de la part de l'otan
aujourd'hui en tout cas
jusque deux points le premier point
c'est que je crois que stratégiquement
si vous voulez aussi bien du côté
brusque du côté américain
cette crise
marque des points de victoire monsieur
poutine enfin discutent directement avec
monsieur bart hayden on se retrouve dans
la position près années 1990 nous sommes
des grandes puissances les autres on
s'en fiche on parle entre nous de
l'autre côté monsieur bart hayden de
regrouper les européens au sein de
l'otan ça arrange beaucoup parce que je
rappelle qu'après kaboul les européens
posait beaucoup de questions aux
américains et là on oublie tout et on se
réunit derrière les américains
maintenant sur la position qu'a donnée
monsieur kaltenberg position de principe
les gens ont rejoint l'otan pas de
problème maintenant je suis assez
d'accord la l'ukraine et la géorgie ce
sont des cas particuliers
je rappelle que depuis des années ils
ont demandé à rejoindre l'otan et que de
but des années la france et l'allemagne
s'y sont toujours opposés parce que si
la france et l'allemagne avaient accepté
l'article 5 aurait joué au moment de
l'invasion du donbass et ça la france l
allemagne ne le voulait pas il ne
voulait pas d'une guerre effectivement
maintenant comme il ya une partie du
territoire occupé forcément il ya
impossibilité de rejoindre le temps donc
c'est une une mauvaise question qu'a
posée monsieur poutine il en est revenu
sur le plan des principes or monsieur
josh green bay ne fait que rappeler les
principes est est ce que wenger compte
il ne s'est pas piéger en en mettant
cette ligne rouge xavier moreau parce
que qu'elle peut être désormais la
réaction de la russie à partir du moment
où il ya cette fin de non recevoir
et non parce que justement s'ils
voulaient la russie ne posent pas
d'ultimatum contrairement à ce qu'on a
dit c'est souvent les occidentaux qui
pose des ultimatums
n'ont cessé c'est en fait la rue quand
quand vous arrivez pour des négociations
enfin vous pouvez voir tous les grands
traités les deux parties à moins qu'il y
ait une capitulation sans condition
arrivent avec des demandes du traité de
vienne ça s'est passé comme ça et donc
les deux parties discutent et après on
va voir à quoi ça aboutit et mon avis on
ne verra pas dans l'immédiat c'est un
processus de discussion qui a commencé
déjà en 2021 et vous verrez vous serez
surpris à l'arrivée mais évidemment que
l'admirent poutine c'est très bien qu'il
ya des choses qui sont demandées et qui
ne peuvent pas être acceptées mais il y
en a d'autres qui le seront et encore
une fois pour l'instant on ne connaît
pas réponse de blink ne sais pas de quoi
ils vont parler la semaine prochaine et
on ne sait pas au prochain sommet
poutine d'haydn ce qui sera décidé est
différente de l'otan la réponse de dans
tony blinken
je dirais plutôt celle inverse
c'est-à-dire qu'elles répondent aux tony
blinken sera celle de l'otan parce que
pour finir les seuls qui décidera le
tancer ses washington c'est pour ça que
encore une fois
c'est donc la verse et la réponse de
l'otan et la réponse de monsieur blinken
9 h quels sont les états unis qui d'été
qui décide alors à la lumière de tous
ces éléments ce soir quel peut être le
point d'accord stoltenberg avant cette
conférence de presse faisait savoir que
les alliés étaient prêts à discuter
indue du désarmement conventionnel du
contrôle des armements stratégiques et
de la transparence des exercices
militaires est ce que ça va suffire pour
un point d'accord mais on en est je
reviens aux accords qui existait avant
et je rappelle aussi que le comité
otan-russie à refonctionner ya quinze
jours il a été réactivé donc il n'est
pas complètement fermée mais ce que je
voudrais rappeler simplement sur la
méthode de négociation par me pardonnez
moi de m'opposer à ce que vous dites
pour avoir pas mal pratiqué aux nations
unies ce système de négociation on
n'arrive jamais avec une feuille en
disant voilà les points et voilà les
mets ligne rouge parce que ça c'est la
fin de la négociation
on arrive avec des positions de
négociation et on termine par une
feuille commune ce qui est assez
différent et donc ce qui me gêne un
petit peu aujourd'hui c'est dans quelle
situation se trouve monsieur poutine il
a mis sur la table un certain nombre de
points qui sont refusés comment va-t-il
revenir en arrière et là on est dans un
problème plus psychologique monsieur
poutine le dja actuelle
et dans un dans un environnement dans
lequel il a assez peu de contradiction
et donc il est difficile de voir comment
ce ayant élevé le débat aussi loin on
peut revenir à un niveau de négociation
alors moi j'ai des espoirs dans le
dialogue normandie qui par miracle un
été qui a été remis sur la table
aujourd'hui alors qu'on n'y croyait plus
c'est une possibilité de sortie je
rappelle que les américains ne sont pas
présents là et à les russes les
ukrainiens les allemands et les français
en
normandie on va quand même terminé parce
que ce qui se passe sur portant en ce
moment avec cette conférence de presse
et ses réponses puisque jusqu'à présent
le dialogue s'était plutôt entre les
américains et la russie je vous
d'écouter
jens stoltenberg pardon qui parle
justement de de cet accord possible avec
la russie nous sommes prêts à les
écouter dit il
nous devrions donc rouvrir nos bureaux
respectifs à moscou et bruxelles
nous devrions également tirer pleinement
parti de nos canaux de communication
entre militaires afin de promouvoir la
transparence et de réduire les risques
et nous devrions envisager d'ouvrir une
ligne d'une ligne prioritaires civile
utilisable en cas d'urgence
deuxièmement la situation la sécurité
européenne y compris la situation en
ukraine et alentours nous sommes prêts à
écouter les préoccupations de la russie
et a engagé un véritable débat sur la
manière de préserver et de renforcer les
principes fondamentaux de la sécurité
européenne auxquels nous avons souscrit
à commencer par l'acte final d'helsinki
cela inclut le droit de chaque nation à
choisir les modalités de sa sécurité
troisièmement la réduction des risques
la transparence et la maîtrise des
armements
l'histoire montre que le dialogue sur
cette thématique peut apporter une
véritable sécurité pour tous ou jeu
javier moro sur ces propositions est ce
que ça peut être de nature justement à
entraîner des escalades dans ce dossier
oui bien évidemment toute manière ce
qu'il faut se rappeler le général si tu
es tout à l'heure le l'accord de survol
à ciel ouvert ce sont les américains qui
en sont sortis ce ne sont pas ce ne sont
pas les russes et effectivement ils
avaient montré au début de la crise
ukrainienne qu'il n'y avait pas de
concentration de forces russes se prête
à envahir l'ukraine alors qu'à l'époque
comme aujourd'hui dans toute la presse
française on nous expliquait que c'était
le cas comme nous a expliqué que c'était
le cas au printemps 2021 donc
effectivement heureux reprendre des
habitudes de ce genre c'est tout à fait
positif mais encore une fois c'est pas
stoltenberg qui veulent décider avec la
russie c'est bannière poutine qui va le
décider avec joe biden j'ai l'impression
que
on s'en rend pas trop compte et quand on
fait en main normandie il s'agit
d'appliquer les accords de minsk
d'accord ça fait sept ans que la france
devrait faire pression sur kiev pour
qu'ils appliquent les accords de minsk
s'affaisse et en décembre 2019 qui est
au rendez vous enfin ma normandie et mal
macron a dit à tort que ça avait abouti
à des choses très positives non ça
aboutit une feuille de route pour le
président céline ski de tous les points
des changes des prisonniers de
2-2-2 comme dire de 2,2 préparer
justement la publication de corée minsk
aucun n'a été n'a été appliquée et c'est
pour ça aujourd'hui que vladimir poutine
s'adresse directement à dubaï donne
pourquoi parler excusez moi à des
vassaux quand on peut parler directement
au seigneur ben c'est ce que fait
vladimir poutine c'est pour ça que ce
résultat est très bon pour vladimir
poutine de toute manière à chaque fois
qu'il ya une relation privilégiée entre
washington et moscou et là je suis
encore d'accord avec le général c'est
une excellente chose pour l'avenir
poutine et je pense même pour la paix
dans la région
non je pense que monsieur joe colton
berck comme dit si vous voulez le temps
est vraiment l'instrument des américains
dans ce cas de figure là et je pense que
autant on peut dire que c'est une
position favorable pour monsieur poutine
pour la posture pour sa posture
puisqu'ils discute avec les états unis
autant ça n'est pas une position
favorable pour le règlement de la crise
parce que le règlement de la crise
pardonnez moi ça concerne d'abord les
européens l'affrontement ça concerne les
russes et les américains pour des
raisons qui n'ont rien à vous avec lui
crée donc ça veut dire que le format
normandie 1 ces diplomates qui sont en
train de négocier en ce moment même à
paris ça peut tout même changer la donne
selon m avec les effets effectivement
qui ont été soulignés c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui des accords de minsk ne
sont pas appliquées ni par l'ukraine ni
par le côté russe et il faut absolument
qu'ils progressent voilà ça c'est ça
c'est une évidence et et donc il faut
qu'ils aient pression des deux côtés de
façon à ce que les ukrainiens c'est là
où la position américaine est dangereuse
à soutenir en permanence les ukrainiens
on oublie que eux aussi ont des
obligations à remplir dans l'accord de
minsk
xavier moreau wii n'ont cessé alors ça
c'est complètement fou déjà les russes
ne sont pas signataires des accords de
minsk vous pouvez télécharger le
document des accords de minsk sur
internet y ait un accord entre kiev et
donetsk est lougansk avec comme témoin
et d'ailleurs ils sont en europe
uniquement représentée par l'ambassadeur
l'eau scee et la russie donc la russie
n'est pas signataire et tout ce qu'elle
avait à faire dans les accords de minsk
c'était de faire pression sur les
républiques autoproclamées pour qu'elles
cessent leur offensive victorieuse
c'était ça et la russie l'a fait
aujourd'hui ni neutre ni donetsk est
lougansk n'a lancé d'offensive vers
marioupol ou verse la violence en
revanche le devoir des angles des
français et des allemands c'était de
faire pression sur kiev pour que il
fasse une amnistie qui est des échanges
de prisonniers et donc il y a des yeux
du transfert de danger j'ai suivi ça
depuis depuis deux ans et finalement il
ne se passe rien et ça et ça bloque du
côté de kiev 5 blocs pas du côté de
moscou qui n'est pas concernée par les
accords de mille sabords uniquement du
côté de kiev et à paris et à berlin
alors en revanche là j'ai vu un point
positif c'est que les mêmes macron dans
sa dernière discussion a dit qu' il est
en gros il l'avait fait renoncer aux
ukrainiens l'adoption d'une loi qui rend
et qui en fait aurait quasiment annulé
les accords de minsk donc ça on va dire
que c'est pour une fois pour la première
fois en huit ans
la france et l'allemagne font pression
sur kiev pour commencer à respecter un
tant soit peu les accords de musc et
bien espérons que ça continue comme ça
encore une fois les décisions seront
prises par washington donc emmanuel
macron un qui va quand même emmanuel
macron lui essayent d'entrer dans le jeu
puisque il va s'entretenir vendredi avec
la nuit routine par par téléphone est ce
que cela peut peser selon vous coûter
mais le président macron essaye d'être
la puissance d' équilibre qui la décrit
et qu'il a décrit lors de son allocution
devant le parlement européen puissance
d'équilibré ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les européens aient leur mot à
dire sur une crise qui concerne l'europe
alors il y ait cei et je répète la faute
est aux américains et à monsieur poutine
de vouloir discuter entre eux deux
sujets qui n'ont strictement rien à voir
avec l'ukraine qui sont des rapports de
puissance j'allais dire c'est on revient
à yalta si vous voulez c'est quand même
un peu dommage après toutes ces années
qu'on revienne à yalta donc aujourd'hui
le président mac on essaye alors il
n'est pas nécessaire d'espérer pour
entreprendre ni de réussir pour
persévérer comme disait le prince
d'orange est bien le président macron va
essayer et nous devons l'encourager à
essayer de régler cette crise comme ça
vous savez mort le mot de la fin il ya
eu quand même des déclarations encore
assez alarmiste de la part de washington
aujourd'hui les états unis qui prédisent
une agression russe dans les trois
semaines ils ont d'ailleurs conseillé à
leurs ressortissants
américains de quitter l'ukraine
j'écoutais
la seule chose qui ferait intervenir la
russie en ukraine c'est une opération
nettoyage ethnique lancé par kiev dans
le dôme bas c'est dans l'eau bouillante
qu'ils en parlent depuis 2014 je pense
qu'ils ne le font pas parce que jean
plus ils n'ont pas auteur obtenu
l'autorisation de washington donc d'ici
trois semaines on verra qui ne se serait
rien passé et donc les choses vont se
calmer et donc peut-être qu'à ce moment
là les américains pourront faire des
concessions puisqu'ils se vanteront
d'être responsables de cette
non-intervention de la russie mais
croyez moi d'ici trois quatre mois on
repartira sur le même psychodrame qu'on
a eu en avril 2021 qu'on a maintenant et
qu'on aura
jusqu'à jusqu'à je sais pas quand tant
que oui moi je pense qu'être quoi être
optimiste
avec les résultats de cette soirée en
effet oui non je suis d'accord et je
crois qu'au bout du compte
les états unis dans cette affaire là ont
réussi quelque chose à un moment
difficile où la france avait réussi à
amener les européens à s'occuper du sud
et du sahel à les ramener vers face à
l'est et donc sous le parapluie de
l'otan donc ressouder les européens
après l'échec catastrophique de kaboul
merci beaucoup en tout cas à tous les
deux éviers moreau
général dominique trinquant d'avoir été
avec nous avoir apporté ce décryptage à
ces derniers développements de ce soir
et autres dossiers qui préoccupent
l'europe de l'est la crise migratoire
avec la pologne qui a lancé hier la
construction d'un mur à sa frontière
avec la biélorussie
objectif stopper l'afflux de milliers de
migrants illégaux à l'origine d'une
crise entre varsovie et minsk l'an passé
les détails avec juliette lamy
un mur pour remplacer les fils barbelés
la pologne a entamé mardi la
construction de sa nouvelle clôture à la
frontière avec la biélorussie
le mur sera aux 2 5 mètres 50
et l'on de 186 km kilomètres offre
sur un mur modernes équipés de capteurs
de mouvement et de caméras thermiques
un projet ultra moderne dont la
construction doit s'achever en juin la
facture elle est estimée à 3 153
millions d'euros un coup qui fait réagir
la population
il aurait été mieux que ce meilleur
coûte moins cher
ce mur ce n'est que de l'argent public
gaspillé les migrants feront des trous
et ils passeront
un scepticisme alors que la situation à
la frontière est toujours tendue
conséquence de la crise diplomatique
entre varsovie
minsk la zone sous état d'urgence est
d'ailleurs toujours interdites d'accès
les gardes-frontière refuse de préciser
l'emplacement des travaux de peur de
voir affluer des candidats à l'exil
pourtant les tentatives de passage ont
drastiquement diminué
[Musique]
actuellement ce sont des groupes plus
petits de quelques individus à une
trentaine de personnes qui essaient dé
traversé illégalement la frontière
polono biélorusse en octobre dernier
c'est groupe comptait plusieurs
centaines de personnes en tout ce sont
des milliers de migrants qui ont tenté
de traverser la frontière polonaise pour
rejoindre le sol de l'union européenne
certains ont réussi d'autres n'ont pas
survécu entre le froid et la faim ils
sont une douzaine à avoir perdu la vie
au cours de leurs tentatives
au royaume-uni boris johnson est de plus
en plus contesté après les affaires du
parti gate le premier ministre
britannique aurait également participé à
une fête d'anniversaire organisée pour
lui on plaint confinement des débats
houleux au lieu aujourd'hui au parlement
l'opposition demande la démission de
boris johnson à londres les précisions
de chadia edwards tashi correspondante
verte et internationale
les questions au premier ministre cet
après-midi ont été houleuses alors que
boris johnson s'accroche et refuse de
démissionner on attend encore les
conclusions qui génère beaucoup
d'anticipation du rapport de sioux gré
mais il n'a pas encore été rendu public
alors que la tante se prolonge nombre de
gens sur les réseaux sociaux disent
qu'ils attendent avec plus d'excitation
même que pour noël et ce même si
beaucoup se demandent si le rapport est
vraiment nécessaire pour confirmer que
boris johnson et ses collègues violait
la loi en pleine pandémie le chef de
l'opposition appellent au départ de
boris johnson disant qu'il a menti à
deux reprises et induit en erreur le
parlement à propos de ces faits
wouah les sextoys moi ça se fait
présumer rudent une stricte ont été
révélés le rapport devrait confirmer au
moins certaines d'entre elles on sait
qu'il y a une le 20 mai 2020 à laquelle
100 personnes auraient été invités afin
de profiter pleinement de la météo et
apportez votre alcool en avril 2021 de
fête aurait eu lieu la même soirée et
pour l'une d'entre elles l'un des
participants seraient même allés à se
réapprovisionner à la supérette du coin
en boisson qui aurait été ramené dans
une valise à roulettes c'était la veille
des funérailles du prince philip downing
street a depuis présenté des excuses
directement à la reine plus récemment on
évoque une fête d'anniversaire pour
boris johnson le 19 juin apparemment 30
personnes étaient rassemblées en
intérieur lorsqu'on a présenté un gâteau
à boris johnson et le personnel a chanté
joyeux anniversaire
pour beaucoup il est certain que le
premier ministre a été pris la main dans
le sac mais boris johnson répète qu'il
ne savait pas qu'il enfreignait les
règles
certains partisans de boris johnson
disent que certaines de ces fêtes
notamment la fête de son anniversaire
n'avait pas été prémédité allan théo
pâtes à emporter
en attendant le rapport de sucré et ses
conclusions certains disent qu'ils
devraient confirmer au moins certaines
des infractions et certains même qu'il
devrait y avoir suffisamment d'éléments
pour suggérer au moins une certaine
illégalité puisque la police londonienne
a ouvert une enquête il est intéressant
de noter que les conclusions du rapport
de sioux gré seront communiquées
directement au premier ministre et à qui
il incombera ensuite de faire une
déclaration à la chambre des communes
certains se demandent la totalité des
conclusions seront elles rendues
publiques ou le premier ministre
décidera at il de faire un tri il est
certain en tout cas que boris johnson
n'aura que quelques heures à la
réception du rapport pour le rendre
public et à chaque minute qui passe les
appels à sa démission à son départ
gagnent davantage en force
et pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales
bonsoir claude blanchemaison boris
johnson à qui s'est défendu l x bec et
ongles à mes enfants que les sauts
l'étau se resserre autour de lui je
crois qu'il est dans l'oeil du cyclone
aujourd'hui boris johnson et il a son
ancien conseiller politique coming qui
répètent partout que hélas d'autres
affaires dansant dans son sac et que
d'autres affaires pourrait pourrait
sortir
il y à lenquête administrative qui est
conduite par la numéro deux de
l'administration du premier ministre qui
devrait trouver des résultats très
bientôt peut-être existe-t-il déjà parce
qu'il ya une nouveauté depuis hier c'est
que la police du grand londres s'est
saisi du dossier et que sa directrice
est intervenu en disant qu'elle avait
des éléments qui faisaient que en effet
une enquête devait être ouverte et
probablement elle a eu accès aux
premières conclusions de l'enquêté
administrative donc boris johnson en
effet est en difficulté mais avec une
enquête de police il a gagné un délai
parce que cette enquête de police elle
va prendre quelques semaines
et donc il ne sera pas ce mai par les
chefs de son parti de démissionner
pendant ces quelques semaines alors le
leader des lib bourrin l'a accusé de
mépriser le pays et le président de la
chambre des communes a dû intervenir à
plusieurs reprises pour maintenir le
calme réprimant d'ailleurs au passage un
député travailliste qui avait qualifié
de boris johnson de menteur est ce qu'on
a à faire une crise politique au royaume
uni donc le leader de l'opposition il
fait son travail c'est à dire qu'ils
critiquent le gouvernement est dans le
système britannique c'est tout à fait
légitime et logique alors évidemment par
ailleurs il ya des députés conservateurs
qui ne sont pas contents et qu'ils le
manifestent ya probablement un début de
révolte notamment chez les plus jeunes
mais je crois que pour le moment boris
johnson arrive aller à les contenir
alors il y aura également d'autres
moyens peut-être de sauver sa peau c'est
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs l'autre jour
la fin des restrictions liées aux
qu'ovide qui somme toute est assez
populaire l'envoi par exemple de
militaires dans la manche pour repousser
les migrants ça suffira redorer le
blason du premier ministre en clair à ce
qu'il va réussir à sauver sa place c'est
important on est en effet pour les élus
conservateurs aux communes puisque ce
sont des libéraux qui veulent en effet
qui est le moins de 2 que de contraintes
possibles venant du gouvernement sur les
citoyens et c'est un peu le sens des
mesures qui ont été décidées en effet il
ya une semaine alors par ailleurs la
marine pour contenir les arrivées de
migrants par la manche ça c'est une idée
déjà ancien je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
très efficace parce que la marine
britannique a l'habitude d'appliquer le
droit international et le droit
international c'est que lorsque les gens
sont en train de se noyer il faut
laisser courir donc reste à voir ce que
fera la marine de sa majesté britannique
autre sujet évidemment on l'a vu dans
votre votre sujet précédent la situation
internationale est très tendue mais
boris johnson salines qui sema tiquement
sur sur joe biden et par conséquent il
n'est pas sûr que ce serait le meilleur
moment pour changer le premier ministre
et pour avoir
une sorte de changements qu'on peut
accomplir gouvernement parce que les
candidats à sa succession sont mises
affaires étrangères émis des finances
donc il est probable que la crise
internationale que nous vivons pas aussi
donné un ballon d'oxygène à boris
johnson alors il n'y a pas même 40% des
électeurs conservateurs qui souhaitent
sa démission 1 qu'en est il vraiment des
britanniques est ce qu'ils vont suivre
effectivement s'il ya 40% des électeurs
conservateurs qui sont pour sa démission
ça fait environ 70 % de l'ensemble des
électeurs britanniques puisque par
définition les travaillistes en contre
lui mais si on regarde ce qui compte
aujourd'hui mais pour cet éventuel vote
de censure c'est les conservateurs
aurillac 15 % des députés conservateurs
qui a moins de 15% en réalité qui sont
contre lui car s'il y en avait 15 % et
du ray 54 signature qui demanderait
au leadership des parties d'entamer la
procédure de défiance et ça n'est pas le
cas et en effet boris johnson s'emploie
parce que ce ne soit pas le cas merci
beaucoup claude blanchou les ans nous
avoir apporté ce décryptage et on verra
un petit peu voilà les derniers
développements dans les prochaines
semaines concernant boris johnson merci
à vous
le libre en signant un accord avec la
jordanie pour l'acheminement
d'électricité via la syrie voisine
objectif pour les autorités améliorer
l'état du secteur de l'énergie du pays
le liban qui subit des coupures de
courant parfois pendant plus de 22
heures par jour à ce constat s'ajoutent
aussi des pénuries d'essence et monnet
fortement dévalué françois xavier
lambert
des poignées de main et des sourires
après la signature d'un accord qui
pourrait soulager de nombreux libanais
grâce à cette entente avec la syrie et
la jordanie
les autorités libanaises espèrent
augmenter la distribution d'électricité
de huit à dix heures par jour dans les
mois à venir le ministre de l'énergie
libanais a salué un moment historique
aujourd'hui nous consolidons l'action
arabe commune sur le plan économique et
social
à travers cet accord modeste mais très
important pour le peuple libanais
là qui a besoin de chaque heure
d'électricité
une satisfaction partagée côté jordanien
syrien le représentant dahmane a mis en
avant une collaboration exemplaire
nous tenons à accroître la coopération
entre les pays arabes et cet accord est
d'autant plus important qu'il intervient
dans des circonstances délicates et
difficiles à laquelle sont confrontés
nos amis au liban ce qui lui donne une
importance supplémentaire
depuis des mois le liban importe du fuel
irakien pour faire fonctionner tant bien
que mal ses centrales électriques mais
certains jours les coupures peuvent
s'étaler sur une vingtaine d'heures pour
gens des quartiers entiers de beyrouth
dans le noir cette crise énergétique se
cumulent à la grave crise no milk qui
secoue le pays depuis trois ans la
monnaie a perdu environ 90% de sa valeur
sur le marché noir et quatre libanais
sur cinq vivent désormais en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté selon l'onu dans ce
contexte le fragile gouvernement
libanais formé en décembre dernier à
entamer de nouvelles discussions avec le
fonds monétaire international
les autorités espèrent obtenir un plan
de sauvetage financier pour relancer une
économie exsangue selon le gouverneur de
la banque centrale le liban aurait
besoin de 12 à 15 milliards de dollars
de prêts et pour en parler nous sommes
avec françois el bacha économie
fondateur de libnanews bonsoir françois
et ben ça merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france le liban
qui a donc signé un accord on vient
d'entendre avec la jordanie pour
l'acheminement d'électricité via la
syrie est ce un réel espoir pour parler
pallier aux pénuries du pays où c'est
l'illustration de d'une misère extrême
dans lequel est plongée désormais liban
bonsoir tout d'abord c'est pas une c'est
une solution temporaire c'est pas une
solution pérenne de 105 ch et 250 mégas
watts le jour c'est 150 mégawats de la
nuit sachant qu'en fait le liban
nécessiterait 3000 mégawatts c'est
qu'actuellement la production
disponibles des causses 2 500 méga watts
ça veut dire que même si on ajoute 250
mégawatts on reste très largement
déficitaire il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
solution
réelle à
au problème de l'électricité ensuite cet
accord doit se doubler d'un autre accord
enfin d'une taille ou d'une autre
solution qui est l'importation de gaz
égyptien à destination de la centrale de
diagral marre des lamas rousseau au nord
du liban qui rajouterait 450 mégawatts
on resterait toujours déficitaire au
niveau de la production donc la solution
à long terme ce n'est pas l'importation
d'électricité c'est pas le gazoduc en
tant que tel c'est aussi augmenté
localement la production d'électricité
en mettait en place de nouvelles
structures et non plus des centrales qui
sont obsolètes et dont le coût
d'exploitation sont très importantes et
qui sont aussi à l'origine
de la problématique du déficit de l'edf
qui coûte 2 milliards de dollars de
prêts par an qui coûtait avant par dont
deux milliards de dollars par an au
liban
la banque mondiale en tout cas donné son
accord de principe mais elle conditionne
quand même cet accord à une hausse du
prix du kilowatt des mesures liées
notamment à la transparence la lutte
contre la corruption et la
restructuration du secteur est ce que le
libre en est capable d'accéder à ses
exigences
techniquement
ce sont des choses qui sont déjà très
dur à mettre en place parce que la
hausse du prix du kilowatt on est en
situation de crise économique ça va être
très dur pour la population d'accepter
un kilowatt 2000 livres quand il coûte à
le voir actuelle de ce 200 livres même
si
en temps dollars ça diminue le pouvoir
d'achat pour un fortement été dégradée
ces deux dernières années
d'autre part l'électricité est un sujet
politique sensible où il ya eu beaucoup
d'interactions politique d'ingérence
politique et il ya eu beaucoup de
corruption de la part de tous les partis
on se souvient que dans les années 90 il
ya une histoire il ya eu un échec par
exemple d'adn appel d'offres pison a
construit une centrale électrique parce
que y avait une histoire d'une
commission de 50 millions de dollars on
a eu des histoires de barrage et ainsi
de suite dans les années 2000 et donc
c'est un sujet très sensible où il ya
une d'ingérence politique
oui les affaires de corruption étaient
encore dernièrement sur l'importation de
fioul on a découvert des histoires de
deux commissions illégales et d'eau
chaude qui était en fait frelaté qui
correspondait pas au cahier des charges
autre fin de la semaine au liban non le
moindre à une figure un symbole de la
politique libanaise a quitté la vie
politique saad hariri s'est pas
seulement le premier ministre libanais
mais c'est l'héritier d'une grande
famille politique au liban alors lui
s'est justifié en évoquant la la forte
influence iranienne les relations
internationales et les divisions
internes que 10 ce départ selon vous
y'a pas seulement l'influencent
iranienne est aussi un manque de soutien
des pays arabes
saad hariri ne bénéficie plus en tant
que tel de la pluie de l'appui de
l'arabie saoudite et ont
même il ya des preuves personnes proches
à lui qui ont dit que lui même aurait
admis que l'arabie saoudite n'était plus
prêt à financer sa campagne électorale
aujourd'hui pour les prochaines
élections législatives
donc il ya beaucoup de facteurs qui
s'étale arrangeant lanvaux
toute la campagne de 2009 par exemple a
coûté un milliard de dollars à certaines
puissances pour permettre pour financer
des partis locaux
en tout cas son son départ intervient
dans un contexte d'effondrement
économique évidemment la banque mondiale
a d'ailleurs qualifié cette situation
comme l'une des plus graves jamais
observées dans le monde
comment vous ce pays va faire ce pour se
remettre et qui a aujourd'hui les
épaules pour prendre la place de saad
hariri
tout d'abord
c'est pas les politiques en fin de
compte qui les tiennent
réellement le pouvoir aujourd'hui dans
ce pays à ce qu'on appelle le parti des
banques c'est ce parti des banques
aujourd'hui qui fait la pluie le beau
temps au niveau économique donc c'est
eux qui ont fait chuter l'ancien
gouvernement à sindia parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas d'accord sur le chiffrage
des pertes du secteur bancaire est
encore aujourd'hui on voit très bien
comment ils ont mis en place le premier
ministre qui lui-même actionnaire de
bank
donc la relance de l'économie libanaise
ça va déprendre de l'acceptation par ce
parti des banques du chiffrage des
pertes du secteur bancaire est autant
qu'on sache ils vont faire porter le
chapeau en majorité aux déposants
puisqu'on évoque des pertes supportées
par les déposants à hauteur de 55%
contre seulement 19% pour les
actionnaires des banques
le liban et
la diminution du justement d'aider les
estimations des pertes du secteur
bancaire va amener probablement une
diminution des exigences possibles pour
le liban par rapport à l'aide
internationale
le précédent gouvernement souhaitait 10
milliards de dollars des du fmi
aujourd'hui on évoque plus que de 4
milliards de dollars et ce sont des
sommes qui sont totalement
insuffisante pour relancer l'économie
libanaise puisque le gouverneur de la
banque du liban évoque lui-même un
chiffre de 12 à 15 milliards de dollars
qui seraient nécessaires d'autres
figures et un dernière évoqué agit de 23
milliards de dollars donc la solution
aujourd'hui n'est pas politique c'est
aussi dans le déblocage et de la
reconnaissance et l'arrêt du déni de ses
intérêts économiques et pour pouvoir
aller faire des choses on parlait tout à
l'heure du problème de l'électricité
aujourd'hui le problème de l'électricité
c'est qu'on n'arrive plus à financer la
mise en place de l'électricité on a des
effondrements des services publics
d'effondrement des services
téléphoniques
qu'à beyrouth la syrie les deux semaines
qui ne marchaient plus faute de fioul on
à l'effondrement aujourd'hui des réseaux
de distribution d'eau à beyrouth et dans
les temps les brillants joint alentours
justement parce que c'est par ces
personnes des blocs en quelque sorte
tous toute possibilité d' aide
internationale et de conclusion rapide
des négociations avec le fmi merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous françois
el bacha
vous avez apporté votre décryptage ce
soir
et direction présent la tunisie qui fait
face dans certaines régions un problème
d'accès à internet au nord-ouest du pays
certaines populations isolées se sont
exclus face à des élus dépourvus de
moyens matériels et financiers l
approche d'une consultation nationale
reportages signés ben hassen chébili
avec les airs nasri et ahmed chalabi
ingram un paradis écologique niché dans
les montagnes du nord-ouest tunisien
semble comme figé dans le temps derrière
ce paysage de carte postale se cache une
toute autre réalité celle d'une région
l'une des plus pauvres du pays en pleine
consultation nationale alors que les
grandes villes tunisiennes enregistrent
des taux de participation croissant
depuis le 15 janvier ici rares sont ceux
qui ont pris part à cette initiative
gouvernementale
pire encore dépourvues d'accès internet
certains n'ont même jamais entendu
parler de ce projet cher au président
sayed une série de questions sur des
thématiques tels que l'économie la
culture l'éducation le numérique ou
encore l'emploi indispensable selon
carthage pour mener à bien les réformes
attendues par les tunisiens
consciente de ce handicap les autorités
ont annoncé la mise en place
d'ordinateurs dans plus de 270 maisons
de jeunes sur tout le territoire
national
objectif inclure le maximum de tunisiens
dans ce processus de sortie de crise à
la maison de jeunes de aïn draham en
dépit de l'installation de six
ordinateurs ce questionnaire n'attire
pas les foules voilà ici c'est l'espace
dédié à la consultation nationale comme
vous le voyez les ordinateurs sont déjà
installés dans cet espace qui est à la
base la buvette de la mjc là où se
réunissent principalement les jeunes de
la ville dans cette région la majorité
des personnes ne sont pas au courant
généralement ce sont ceux qui sont
équipés d'internet les populations
cultiver les jeunes les étudiants toutes
ces personnes sont au courant de cette
consultation mais ceux qui habitent un
peu plus loin dans les campagnes et dans
les montagnes eux ne sont pas au courant
a kid hormis cela nous avons constaté
qu'il n'y a pas un réel intérêt
dans cette région montagneuse où le taux
de chômage atteint les 25 6% la
population comme les collectivités
locales semble avoir perdu espoir un
constat que fait nadia mazni nerfs de
aïn draham qui par manque de moyens et
de directives peine à faire exister
cette enquête nationale auprès de ses
administrés
vous savez pour nous ici concernant
cette consultation nationale nous
n'avons reçu aucune directive des
autorités que ce soit en terme de
campagne de communication ou même de
logistique aucun panneau publicitaire
aucune campagne de sensibilisation
ici ce n'est pas comme à tunis nous
sommes une petite collectivité et la
plupart de nos administrés n'ont jamais
entendu parler de cette consultation
à mon niveau je ne sais pas comment
porter cette information la population
je pense à travers le site de la mairie
où grâce aux associations locales
ici les associations semblent s'être
substituée aux collectivités locales
comme ultime contacts entre tunis et ses
régions oubliées actif dans le milieu
associatif depuis plus de 15 ans sabri
se bat chaque jour pour maintenir auprès
des hommes et des femmes de sa région un
sentiment d'appartenance d'existence en
tant que tunisien et citoyens à part
entière un autre en cassation en tant
qu'association nous avons organisé des
tournées à la rencontre des populations
les plus reculées et nous nous sommes
rendu compte que la plupart des
habitants n'ont aucune idée de cette
consultation nationale et quand nous
leur avons posé la question ils nous ont
répondu qu'ils n'ont pas accès à ces
informations diffusées principalement
sur internet et certains nous ont même
confié qu'internet c'est quelque chose
dont ils entendent seulement parler
quand je leur pose la question est ce
que vous savez ce qu'est la consultation
nationale ils te répondent
automatiquement qu'est ce que c'est que
ça et quel est l'intérêt de connaître ça
si ça ne changera pas ma vie ni mon
quotidien le seul fait que dans
consultation nationale il y as nationale
nous poussent à poursuivre notre mission
par le biais de rencontres pour
expliquer à la population rurale le but
de cette consultation la façon d'y
participer d'utiliser cette application
pour créer en eux un sentiment
d'existence comme citoyens à part
entière une mission délicate reflets
d'une toute autre réalité celle de ces
ruraux qui ont l'impression d'être
exclus du système
personnellement cette consultation je
n'y comprends rien je n'en avais même
pas entendu parler et ces choses là
n'ont jamais été quelque chose qui nous
intéresse j'ai entendu dire qu'il
fallait une connexion internet pour
participer mais nous n'avons pas
internet une chose de plus qui prouve
que nous resterons toujours les exclus
la seule chose que nous souhaitons c'est
que notre quotidien change vous savez il
y a des gens ici qui vivent dans une
grande précarité
vous pouvez voir par vous même quasiment
tout le monde est au chômage ici nous
sommes trois générations à vivre dans
cette petite maison et on n'a rien vu ni
de kayes cède ni des précédents
gouvernements pour améliorer notre vie
vous savez je vais être honnête avec
vous si cette consultation change
quelque chose dans ma vie je serai avec
lui sinon c'est le dernier de mes soucis
alors que près de cent mille tunisiens
ont donné leur avis sur la plateforme
dédiée la consultation nationale dans le
gouvernorat de jendouba dont un drame
fait partie moins de 2000 citoyen
participer sur les 47 me que compte ce
territoire un triste constat qui ne
finit pas de mettre en exergue
l'exclusion persistante de cette région
au processus de transition démocratique
de la tunisie
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
la crise sanitaire en france le nom
quotidien de contamination en variant
mikron continue grimper alors que le
pass vaccinale est lui entré en
application ce lundi un véritable casse
tête pour les restaurateurs notamment
dans notre rubrique enfance des français
nous irons à la rencontre de l'un
d'entre eux à paris un patron qui
aujourd'hui se dit prêt à baisser les
bras son témoignage a retrouvé juste
après cette courte pause
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
le new york times le washington post se
doit
de rigueur
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
l'actualité économique de la semaine
décryptées par olivier delamarche le rsa
remplit-il ses objectifs non à en croire
un rapport de la cour des comptes
comment voulez-vous avec un peu plus de
500 euros vous en tirez et vous loger et
c'est donc évidemment que c'est pas un
tremplin pourquoi de ce soir je pense
que le dispositif aura et une efficacité
si on est dans une économie réellement
solidaire pour à l'édition 2022 choose
france 21 projets d'investissements ont
été annoncées en france il ya une
contrepartie qu'on va promettre à des
entreprises si elles viennent
s'implanter que d'abord on les embêtera
pas trop sur les licenciements qu'ils
annonceront après et vous aurez une
déduction fiscale ou des aides pour vous
installer pendant une période donnée
méfiez-vous qu'on l'appelle pas bientôt
loose france aussi
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous cet
écho positif n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent là l on soit vient de
l'ignorance aujourd'hui une gauche
extrêmement utile
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
laventure c'est pas tellement l'aventuré
scientifique et c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
[Musique]
il
un certain nombre de journalistes que
semble s'être octroyé un pouvoir de
juger un pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens j'ai
cherché j'ai su trouver des réponses
mais émettra 20 suis jamais à oger une
qualité ou une compétence ou une
expertise que je n'avais pas je pense
que notre métier devrait un peu douté de
ses bases et les revoir et les remettre
en question a toujours eu un rôle
historique pour le meilleur et pour le
pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était un
petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio c'est
si c'est grave ou si c'est pas grave
plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire la crise sanitaire depuis le
début de l'année un français sur dix a
été testé positif aux copines idée hier
un nouveau cap a été franchi plus d'un
demi million de cas de contamination
recensé des chiffres également en hausse
à l'hôpital le nombre de contaminations
vario omikron continue de grimper alors
que le pass vaccinale est entrée en
application ce lundi un véritable casse
tête pour les restaurateurs notamment un
autre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous irons la rencontre de l'un
d'entre eux à paris un patron qui
aujourd'hui se dit à deux doigts de
baisser les bras
[Musique]
la france est championne d'europe du
nombre de contaminations aux copies de
19 plus de 500000 donc nouvelle
contamination ont été recensés en 24
heures un chiffre jamais atteint depuis
le début de la pandémie un record qui
surprend les experts dans un pays où la
stratégie vaccinale a été massivement
adopté par la population nicolas
fontaine
alors que le pass vaccinale vient
d'entrer en vigueur et que les autorités
sanitaires prévoyait une décrue du
nombre de contaminations dues aux
variants au micron la france vient
d'enregistrer un record des cas de co
vide depuis le début de la pandémie il y
à bientôt deux ans à compter du mois de
janvier 2022 un français sur dix a été
testé positif selon kovy tracker un
chiffre de contamination en envolées
constante puisque le nombre de cas a
doublé depuis cette date une
recrudescence qui pourrait s'expliquer
par la découverte d'un nouveau variant
le sou variant ba2 qui bénéficierait
d'un net avantage de transmission sur au
micron on a constaté qu'un nouveau
variant un sou variant de mikron omikron
classique que l'on appelle la b1 et bien
souvent riant à b2 semble exister et
pourrait peut-être expliquer le fait que
les contaminations progresse outre la
contagiosité du variant est souvent
riendeau micron plusieurs autres
facteurs peuvent expliquer ces chiffres
notamment l'école où les gestes
barrières sont plus difficiles à mettre
en place
le virus circule de façon intense chez
les plus jeunes et se propage ensuite
aux parents autre hypothèse possible le
nombre de tests pratiqués qui est un des
plus élevé en europe et notamment le
recours aux auto test qui contribuent
éventuellement à augmenter le taux de
positivité dans les bases de données
pour d'autres observateurs ce chiffre
pourrait également être dûe à un niveau
de rappel vaccinal en baisse malgré
cette augmentation du nombre de cas le
gouvernement tient à afficher une
relative sérénité arguments de la
dangerosité très minime du variant au
micro
avec ce variant plus encore qu'avant le
nombre de contaminations devient un
indicateur moins révélateur de la
dangerosité et de l'impact de l'épidémie
c'est donc bien sur l'hôpital que nos
yeux sont rivés et la vague omicron il
sévit encore
le nombre d'hospitalisations or et
animations continuent de croître et
dépasse les 30 mille personnes
hospitalisées un chiffre qui n'avait pas
été atteint depuis longtemps
dans son allocution du jour gabriel
attal a confirmé la levée des dernières
restrictions encore en vigueur fin des
jo j'ai du télétravail le 2 février
réouverture des discothèques dès le 16
février l secteur de la restauration
fait partie des plus touchés par la
crise sanitaire nous sommes allés à la
rencontre d'un patron de restaurant dans
le 19e arrondissement de la capitale
pour savoir comment il se débrouille
estelle farges reportage
je suis dans le 19e arrondissement de
paris je vais rencontrer olivier les
restaurateurs depuis deux ans les
restaurateurs vite avec la crise
sanitaire alors dans quel état d'esprit
et il commence organise-t-il on va aller
lui demander
bonjour olivier bonjour reste à leur
merci beaucoup de nous recevoir dans
votre restaurant merci olivier ça fait
trois ans que vous êtes ouverts dont
deux sous une crise sanitaire comment ça
va aujourd'hui
cela va comme des gens dont on dit
qu'ils ont dit
la politique commerciale qui doivent
mener donc c'est plutôt tendue on est
dans des situations extrêmement tendue
actuellement aujourd'hui donc on a le
pass vaccinale avant il y avait le pas
et sanitaires est ce que ça va changer
concrètement le 7 changements de passe
ça nous a coupé d'une certaine clientèle
on a le télétravail
aussi un qui le nous 2010 à nous impacte
ont d'ailleurs à quasiment moins 70 % de
chiffre d'affaires après le soir il ya
une clientèle aussi de jeunes et ses
acquis
qui aujourd'hui a appris aussi à faire
la fête dit autrement au moment de
l'apéro quand même on passe depuis de
consommation de beaucoup de consommation
au comptoir et c'est sur des choses qui
sont en dehors un petit peu des modes de
fonctionnement d'une certaine clientèle
donc toute cette clientèle là on la perd
non seulement la paire mais j'ai pas sûr
que cela protège parce que à côté de ça
il se retrouve dans des apparts où là il
ya aucun contrôle là où il n'y a aucune
mesure de distanciation et c est donc
finalement eu cela change pas
grand-chose à leur vie et par contre ça
pénalise l'économie et nos business
après je pense qu au niveau de
l'information il ya eu
une campagne qui a été pas suffisante il
ya beaucoup de gens qui étaient un petit
peu perdues savait pas comment ils
passaient de passes sanitaire a pas ce
vaccinale
voilà qui on avait tous les gens qui
venaient et qui fonctionnait avec les
tests 1 qui aujourd'hui n'ont plus accès
s'ils rentrent pas dans un schéma
vaccinal nous c'est pas à nous de
décider si c'est bien ou c'est mal nous
on a juste à appliquer ce qu'on fait
donc aujourd'hui on est un petit peu le
bras armé la politique gouvernementale
sur ce sujet là aujourd'hui avec le pass
vaccinale les restaurateurs sont aussi
autorisés à contrôler l'identité de
leurs clients vous comment est-ce que
vous quel est votre regard sur ce qui a
été décidé sur votre nouveau rôle entre
guy et moi je vérifie les passes mais je
vérifie pas les pièces d'identité je ne
demande pas des policiers de venir faire
la cuisine chez moi faut pas me demandez
moi on dit si on a un doute mais sur
quelle base je veux avoir un doute voyez
on va créer dont va créer du conflit on
va créer de la tension est réellement en
ce moment c'est déjà suffisamment tendue
pour qu'on n'ait pas besoin de rajouter
des situations conflictuelles avec notre
clientèle un qui déjà continuent à venir
ici depuis l'entrée en vigueur des
nouvelles mesures restrictives on vous
demande encore des consommations des
choses que vous êtes amené à refuser
savez c'est culturel les personnes qui
s'arrêtent la journée ils ont envie de
leur petit café petit café verdoso
emploi du temps de s'asseoir ils ont
envie de le prendre là comme ça
rapidement deux minutes et prennent leur
petit café ils s'en vont aujourd'hui on
leur dit non qui voulions aller
s'asseoir
olivier vous étiez une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires de 70 % comment est-ce que ça
va se passer maintenant pour vous au
niveau des aides alors il ya plusieurs
êtres qu'ils auront été mises en place
par le gouvernement dont notamment pour
les mois de décembre et janvier
globalement jour nuit sur le mois de
décembre j'ai fait -32% donc sur un
palier où on a une sous les 30% où on
est on a une dette qui est déclenché de
quel montant sous quelle forme j'en sais
rien mon comptable m'a dit que eux mêmes
avaient une formation qui me reviendrait
vers moi après ça y est donc on est sur
des choses qui sont un petit peu
complexe puisque le mode de calcul des
aides a complètement changé depuis le
dernier confinement ça fait deux ans
qu'on est sans visibilité que
systématiquement on peut pas se projeter
à plus de quelques semaines
donc là on espère que tout va se rouvrir
bientôt février ou mars mais même là
c'est compliqué investir se projeter sur
l'été faire des investissements pour
l'été on bloque tout en permanence parce
qu'on se dit
qu' on n'est pas à l'abri de nouvelles
mesures restrictives et dans ces cas là
c'est de l'argent perdu c'est de
l'argent jeté en l'air la quel regard
vous portez sur sur l'avenir
concrètement
j'espère très sincèrement que on va s'en
sortir sinon je fais partie de ceux qui
envisageront de faire autre chose
se projeter c'est donc le souhait de
nombreux entrepreneurs mais comment
faire surtout quand on voit que les
contaminations continue malgré la
campagne vaccinale pas facile de s'y
retrouver alors passez vaccinale et
record de contamination le cap est il
bon on attend vos réactions sur notre
compte télégramme et passe au débat avec
nos invités
[Musique]
avec nous ce soir pour en parler on
dirait que danièle obono député la
france insoumise de paris soutien de
jean luc mélenchon bonsoir danièle obono
merci d'être avec nous valérie de bord
oratrice cellule riposte de valérie
pécresse candidate les républicains à la
présidentielle 2022 un je parle bien de
valérie pécresse et pas de vous voyez
d'abord merci d'être avec nous et sur ce
plateau avec nous philippe bourrier iasi
conseiller régional écologiste en ile de
france et vous êtes-vous soutien de
yannick jadot lui aussi candidat à la
présidentielle merci à tous les trois
d'être là le cap est bon à nous dit
optimiste gabriela talent ce midi alors
c'est vrai que quand on voit ce
restaurateur on a quand même quelques
petits doutes notamment sur la stratégie
du du pass vaccinale qui fait grincer
des dents la plupart des candidats à la
présidentielle nous la broche seront à
même lit jean luc mélenchon à plusieurs
reprises c'est une ineptie danièle obono
pour la france l'insoumise passe
vaccinale
c'est surtout qu'il est inefficace par
rapport aux objectifs que le
gouvernement prétend avoir par rapport à
la pandémie il ne s'agit pas d'empêcher
les contaminations puisque le vaccin ne
le permet pas ça réduit les formes
graves ce qui est utile et nécessaire
mais en vérité objectif ça a été de
faire une forme d' obligation vaccinale
déguisés et c'est ça le problème c'est
que le gouvernement a fait du vaccin la
seule réponse alors qu'elle ne peut être
la seule réponse et il le fait d'une
manière qui stigmatise une partie de la
population dont je rappelle pour les
personnes non vaccinées 40% n'est pas
vaccinée parce que l ils n'ont pas accès
aux soins donc c'est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement y compris
qu'une partie des personnes non
vaccinées elles ne sont pas et quant à
celles et ceux qui ne le sont pas par
choix toutes les études et tout le
travail y compris de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui dit qu'il faut
convaincre et non contraindre montre que
c'est la pire manière de procéder que
d'avoir ce genre d'attitude en vérité
avec le pass vaccinale le gouvernement
et emmanuel macron cliente en pagne fait
un coup politique il s'agit de désigner
les vaccinés qui seraient des bons
citoyens et qui s'identifierait à lui et
à sa politique et puis les non vaccinés
qui sera qui sont présentés comme des
boucs émissaires tout cela n'a rien à
voir avec la question de la pandémie
parce qu'il faudrait faire une politique
plus globale et et voilà pourquoi ces
problématiques et voilà pourquoi
effectivement nous sommes opposés au pas
de sanitaires nous sommes opposés aux
pattes vaccinale et nous mettrons en
place une autre politique d'aller vers
une politique avec des moyens comme par
exemple les touristes qu'à tort aux
vendeurs dans les écoles on est
troisièmes m danièle obono on va on va
en parler parce soit vaccinale et record
de contamination le cap est il bon c'est
la question qu'on vous poser aussi
ajouté des spectateurs sur télégramme
une première réaction peut être la
réaction de david le pass 1 n'avait déjà
rien de sanitaires la preuve vous avez
vu l'explosion du nombre des
contaminations il faut des masques ffp2
partout nous mettre sous masque se
dévide c'est aussi votre avis chez
yannick jadot yannick jadot lui il dit
on est à l'écouté des cils et des
scientifiques et ils ne recommandent pas
le pass vaccinale le gouvernement fait
fausse route selon vous philippe borgat
shi binbin complètement il va droit dans
le mur et il n'est pas prêt de faire
machine arrière effectivement nous les
écologistes nous sommes attentifs à ce
que les scientifiques nous annonce parce
que c'est eux c'est leur job c'est leur
spécialité et donc on a une confiance
totale envers les scientifiques l'om est
ce le rien son mondiale de la santé
ainsi que le conseil scientifique
français ne recommande pas une
vaccination obligatoire donc
certains moi je me base sur les rapports
de l'om est ce je pense que ça peut tous
nous mettre d'accord je ne suis pas
spécialiste et donc j'ai une totale
confiance en eux aujourd'hui
effectivement on assiste à une explosion
il ya cinq cent mille cas donc ne pas
sanitaires étaient inefficaces le pass
vaccinale va suivre le même chemin on va
arriver à un moment donné sur un plateau
enfin une fois que le pic sera passée
puis une décrue est la conjonction entre
les deux que fait emmanuel macron c'est
de dire vous voyez que grâce à la
vaccination
nous avons un taux minimum au moment où
va arriver les élections pour pouvoir en
tirer les fruits et la couverture vers
lui sauf que effectivement si vous ne
mettez pas dans les écoles les fameux
purificateur d'heure les détecteurs de
co2 on voit maintenant qu'ils ont encore
du mal à fournir des masques ffp2 aux
profs toute cette multiplication la
vaccination bien évident danièle obono
l'a très bien dit le aller vers
convaincre plutôt que contre 1 d'envoi
d'ailleurs les magnifiques reportages
vous avez fait sur la croix rouge qui va
vers les gens qui sont éloignés de la
médecine et ils passent du temps à
convaincre a expliqué à chaque fois
qu'ils prennent 20 minutes 25 minutes
avec un patient de l'année finissent par
obtenir son consentement et le vacciner
al'inverse le gouvernement veut y aller
au bulldozer fracturé la population nous
monter les uns contre les autres pour
tout simplement masquer son incompétence
et son efficacité alors on va se tourner
vers un valérie de bord parce que je
suis républicain cette histoire de
passes vaccinale est loin de faire
consensus 1 valérie pécresse elle-même
du un petit peu rétro pédaler passer des
classes sur hon puisqu'elle voulait je
suis privé les non-vaccinés de de
liberté on n'a pas dire merde et les non
vaccinés m'enfin on n'était peut-être
pas loin valérie de bord il faut
peut-être préciser sa pensée chez les
républicains au risque de voeux ou
confondre avec emmanuel macron
caricaturaux
si vous voulez c'est beaucoup trop au
sérieux c'est beaucoup trop important
pour rentrer dans une polémique
politicienne
moi j'écoute les mexicains parce que je
parle de beaucoup de personnes qui
disent voilà ils font tomber les
républicains zinc voilà c'était l'objet
de détourner vous départ mais les propos
de valérie pécresse
moi je regarde ce qui s'y dit chez moi
au chu de nancy
les médecins pis les médecins disent il
faut se faire vacciner
effectivement il y à davantage de cas
parce que le test davantage mais il ya
beaucoup moins de gens qui sont en
réanimation il ya moins de décès moi ce
que je regarde c'est bien être de nos
populations c'est ça qui est important
ce qui est important c'est que si on ne
met pas autant de personnes qui étaient
vaccinés on se retrouverait avec des
taux d'incidence et de gravité bien plus
important alors c'est facile
effectivement
de vouloir jeter l'opprobre et jetés nos
proches c'est aussi jeter l'opprobre sur
l'ensemble d'une profession une
profession qui est saine des médecins
qui disent tous qu'il faut effectivement
se faire vacciner donc ça des soignants
des infirmiers qui ont levé l'ensemble
de leurs voix pour demander à l'ensemble
de la classe politique d'arrêter de
faire de la politique politicienne sur
ce sujet bien nous ça a été ce que nous
avons souhaité faire faire en sorte
effectivement david tout regarder ce qui
pouvait être l'intérêt de l'ensemble des
français le aller vers je suis désolé ça
fait deux ans qu'on fait du aller vers
mais un certain nombre de personnes qui
n'accèdent pas c'est un fait ils sont
très très loin des 44 cents les gens qui
ne sont pas vaccinés aujourd'hui
poursuivre je ne sais pas d'où ils
sortent certainement
[Musique]
des études scientifiques il a
certainement pas beaucoup de références
en tout cas ce qu'a écopée sont ceux de
la croissance sinon on va donner ma
donnez moi les références scientifiques
de cette étude donne et mettre la
pression des mois les références
scientifiques on les chope études de
lettres donnez moi c'est pas ce choc
donnez moi c'est on va laisser paraître
l élite de bord terminée
on le vit réponse il
valéry demory la terre préparée à
l'automne madame la nabo bonhomme aucune
référence c'est facile de jeter des
chiffes c'est facile dans le voyez c'est
facile de dire des choses comme ça il
faut être responsable adam quand on est
un parti de gouvernement mais vous
n'êtes pas un parti de gouvernement
quand on est un parti de gouvernement
les républicains sous la partie drake de
gouvernement nous sommes aujourd'hui ont
nécessité de protéger l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens on a vu cette façon de faire
objectivement mais pas très digne
a essayé ce mot peut faire tous les
trois danièle obono je sais que vous
êtes habitué aux réponses l'ont donc je
voudrais que vous fassiez s'il vous
plaît aussi ridicules alors que mon
intervention n'avait rien contre les
républicains et madame a choisi de faire
une réponse politicienne absolument
indigne donc je lui demandais ce que
vous connaissez l'inserm madame est ce
que ça vous semble vraiment l'habitude
de l'ex fab l inserm ça s'appelle bien
terne les liquides
malheureusement
je pense que tout le monde est témoin du
fait que cette personne ne connaît pas
d'une scène et remet en cause le travail
des scientifiques de l'inserm
je demande donc la région d'adana
jambonneau est responsable on va sortir
de cette polémique de 2,6 voilà vous
n'êtes pas d'accord et c'est
pas d'accord cette personne est
ignorante et dit dépité sur votre plage
ont donc il n'y a pas d'équivalence
entre le fait de remet sur le fait voilà
quatre mois danièle obono on va vous
laisser répondre sur le fait voilà
valérie de bord vous dit on en appelle
son opinion et quand même aussi répondu
attendre la société française dont il
faut la réflexion quand même on en
appelle à la responsabilité des français
voilà il y en a moins en réanimation
qu'est ce que vous répondez à à cela
tout simplement vous à la france inscrit
mise ben on demain je pense que si on
veut avoir un travail sérieux et
respectueux des faits on évite de mettre
en cause les instituts comme l'inserm
des sociologues j'ai vérifié jérémy
world qui travaillent à l'inserm et qui
a fait cette étude très sérieuse nous
nous basons effectivement ce que dit le
ms qui dit il faut convaincre et compte
et non pas contraindre nous pensons que
le vaccin et je les dis en premier
madame si vous aviez écouté plutôt que
de chercher à pinailler et à remettre en
cause le sérieux de ce que nous faisons
depuis deux ans à l'assemblée nationale
nous disons depuis le début que le
vaccin est utile jean-luc fenaison
faisait partie des premiers dirigeants
occidentaux à avoir
signé avec notamment lula le président
du brésil une demande de la levée des
brevets pour permettre est-ce que ce
vaccin soit accessible à toute la
planète à tous les pays qui le demandent
notamment l'afrique du sud et l'inde qui
sont en capacité d'en produire est ce
que vous vous soutenez la levée des
brevets madame est ce que vous pensez
que si bien sûr que c'est le sujet il y
bien sûr que je vais je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi madame parce que tant
le ms dit qu'il faut qu' il y ait au
moins 60% de l'ensemble de la planète
qu'ils soient vaccinés de la pop de la
population ciel si on veut mettre un
terme à la pandémie c'est à dire à
l'épidémie mondiale et que on multiplie
les doses les rappels et c'est
uniquement dans les pays développés
comme la france ou les états unis eh
bien on ne fera jamais face à la
pandémie et ça ce sont des faits vous
pouvez remettre en cause également l'eau
à metz mais quand on est conscient
conséquent sur la grille à monza il est
pour y arriver je sentais mon genou est
totalement sur la même ligne en fait
yannick jadot et jean luc mélenchon
devrait peut-être faire un accord on
lâche résidentiel ça c'est ça leur
incombe mais effectivement je rejoins
complètement et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
j'avais dit dans l'introduction la ligne
de danièle obono moi je pensais que
madame était une partisante de emmanuel
d'accrocs on voit que valérie pécresse
est bonne à mâcon sont sur la même
longueur d'onde c'est vrai que entre
droite on a un petit peu du mal à faire
la différence mais je
m'adapte vos propos sont sont vraiment
violent madame la députée danielle obono
et moi-même dès le départ nous avons dit
que nos formations politiques nos
candidats sont pour la vaccination août
l'association violents dans les
poubelles
république ils sont un peu méprisant en
voulant nous nous cornard ise en disant
que nous sommes des gens irresponsables
nous sommes pour la vaccination madame
sauf que nous n'avons pas la même
approche sur la méthode vous avez une
méthode frontale d'ailleurs excusez moi
mais il ya eu il n'y a pas eu de
discipline de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale concernant votre votre votre
groupe et donc ça je vous laisse laver
votre linge à l'intérieur et et tirer
les oreilles s'il faut tirer les
oreilles mais vous avez été un type en
discute et moi nous ce que nous disons
c'est nous sommes pour la vaccination
est depuis le début yannick jadot a été
le premier le premier avant même que la
vaccination soit mise en place
d'ailleurs on l'avait fait quelques
critiques nous disons effectivement
qu'il faut lever les brevets si vous ne
vacciner pas les pays du tiers monde si
vous ne vous en afrique c'est 8 % de
personnes qui sont vaccinées et si vous
ne vacciner pas vous allez vous
retrouver avec de nouveaux variants mais
on va centrer dans la même étape tout le
temps encore et encore et encore le
gouvernement est un gouvernement de
fouillis de cafouillis on nous a dit
c'est six mois pour le rap est depuis
cinq mois plus 4 mois puis maintenant
trois mois nous sommes complètement
dépassés des français sont son ans reste
permanente est donc maintenant il faut
non simplement on est rassuré il faut
leur donner un message cohérent et vous
ne participez pas malheureusement alors
que je connais votre sérieux madame vous
ne participez pas à ce débat et vous les
kanari's et madame pro bono qui a fait
un travail sérieux et remarquable et les
écologistes qui ont été à la pointe est
à l'avant garde sur la vaccination donc
arrêtons la politique politicienne et
parlons français essaierons de les
convaincre pour qu'ils puissent vacciner
au lieu de les mépriser comme le fait le
gouvernement c'est que nous sommes du
gouvernement un petit peu confus mélange
78 ans qui viennent nous écrire d'accord
avec vous le cap est illisible un audit
elle sortait des gravas on ne peut pas
se projeter tous les candidats à la
présidentielle ont intérêt à prendre
position contre c'est un grave recul de
nos libertés valérie de mort ça c'est
vrai que c'est une critique qui revient
souvent ce recul des libertés
votre réponse
si vous voulez nous des éléments sur
lesquels nous étions en désaccord
c'était le contrôle de l'identité qui
part c'était un petit peu le reportage
que vous faisiez avec notre restaurateur
nous considérons que un restaurateur
quel qu'il soit n'est pas forces de
l'ordre et n'a pas à faire ce contrôle
d'identité titre et on voit très bien
que là on est aux limites de ce système
après moi ce que je reproche aux
personnes qui effectivement ne milite
pas pour le pass maximale c'est que en
fait c'est aussi une façon de pas donné
le signal de la possibilité de se guérir
la possibilité de ne pas être malade
pardon aujourd'hui doit malheureusement
trop de gens qui sont aujourd'hui en
réanimation qui ne sont pas vaccinés
neuf personnes sur dix qui sont
actuellement en réanimation sont des
gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés et c'est
quand même dommage de laisser à penser
que aujourd'hui bien ça n'est pas
possible c'est ça me fait que je trouve
extrêmement dommageable dont ces
positionnements et puis après renvoyé
sur des considérations qui certes sont
importantes par rapport aux brevets mais
c'est comme oubliée la responsabilité
qu'on a ou sein du territoire national
avec responsabilité
elle est grande donc c'est ça
aujourd'hui qu'il me semble extrêmement
important
après faire de la politique politicienne
en disant vous avez le même comportement
qu'untel ou untel quand elle reste un
comportement est responsable on doit
être responsable quand il est
irresponsable et bien il donne et doit
être dénoncée en tant que responsable et
c'est pas en hurlant le contraire que ça
va changer la réalité des choses dont la
société brevets êtes vous pour la lever
mais monsieur monsieur monsieur sas est
dilatoire c'est pas très content et
dilatoire c'est dilatoire moi je vous
dis que le débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est le pass d'axial sur le
pas de vaccination y est je trouve
irresponsable de être bienvenu au moment
de la médiation nous avons travaillé de
concert avec les européens la réponse
allait mondiale n pandémie mondiale on
n'est pas tout seul dans un village de
gaulois et le reste autour de nous miley
cyrus
des millions de doses
quand même réservation daily mail
non absolument pas les promesses n'ont
pas été donnés je sais que vous êtes
aujourd'hui la porte-parole d' emmanuel
macron madame mais ces promesses n'ont
pas été tenues et les pays une ville de
demain charité les pays ne demande pas
la charité il demande la possibilité de
pouvoir produire eux mêmes une cas de
l'afrique du sud et c'est le cas de
langues et franchement moi je n'ai pas
envie de polémiquer avec cette dame je
voulais juste lui donner la référence de
l'enquète hlavackova kh3 d'accès nation
des enfants intentions de vaccination
contre le convient d usage d'une
application tous en piste qu'au vivre
qui part de ses 40 % donc vous irez
vérifier je pense que les personnes non
non non
écouter jusqu'au bout l'étude porte sur
trois y compris l'intention de
vaccination en général madame donc
approuvé les malades sont des enfants je
vous donnais les petits trop longtemps
écouté jusqu'au bout donc arrêtez avec
ça nous avons été constants depuis deux
ans à l'assemblée nationale si vous êtes
sérieuse vous suivez les débats y
compris nous avons eu des accords avec
les députés aient l'air sur la question
des droits et libertés et pas simplement
sur la question du contrôle c'est une
question qui remet en cause les libertés
fondamentales et ça pose question il ya
eu des débats quand nous avons essayé
d'en avoir il est dépité
après le mot de la fin pour philippe
borgat celle ce qu'on arrive à la fin de
notre débat s'il vous plaît oui valérie
d'abord certains qui est certain si vous
voulez c'est que aujourd'hui ce qui est
important c'est d'encourager le post bac
final c'est que moi je considère que
tout ceux qui ne le font pas
effectivement près d'une grande part de
responsabilité il joue avec la santé des
français c'est une réalité et que
aujourd'hui je trouve les propos de
madame obono bien qu proches de ceux du
rassemblement rassemblement national en
l'espèce avec cette volonté en fait de
vouloir monter les gens les uns contre
les autres que ça c'est pas acceptable
et remettre remettre en cause les
scientifiques remettre en cause les
soigneurs remettre en cause les gérer
qui aujourd'hui risques aussi
leur vie que soigner les français bien
je trouve que ce n'est pas responsable
c'est les vivants c'est tout c'est aussi
philippe braud est assez le mot de la
fin pour vous et rapidement s'il vous
plaît on avait vraiment la rage je suis
consterné et comparer les membres de la
france insoumise aura au rassemblement
national sur ce point vraiment vous
faites déshonneur à votre parti écoutez
il y a un problème de santé majeur nous
avons des contrats compatriotes qui sont
en train de mourir au lieu de tous
travailler ensemble pour aller dans le
même sens vous essayer de tirer la
couverture vers vous pour une élection
présidentielle c'est juste lamentable
c'est vraiment dommage parce que j'avais
vraiment une autre image de vous et
notre image de votre présidence mais bon
effectivement entre choisir entre la
marque renaît et valérie pécresse on va
avoir du mal à faire la différence merci
à tous les trois merci fini bon il ya
aussi la mairie de bord et danièle obono
mais
bon voilà genre on va offrir un bon
bouquin dit le serbe avait les rites de
bord peut-être voilà pour noël vous
pourriez comme ça ça vous réconciliera
toutes les deux mais
bon voilà oh merci en tout cas toutes
les deux et rendez vous demain 20h pour
un nouveau numéro d'ici là n'oubliez pas
de réagir de commenter de poster vos
questions sur le télégramme daté france
excellente auraient tous
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et la population
africaine c'est un milliard d'habitants
c'est ça à la valeur de nos crypto mener
notre objectif c'est d'avoir de plus en
plus de partenaires qui acceptent notre
crypto comme moyen de paiement qu'en ce
crash qui nous ont dit que l'argent
liquide perd de la valeur beaucoup de
pays en afrique ont interdit la crypto
est ce que vous répondez à cela une
planète on ne peut pas dire on va
interdire la crypto autant qu'il ya
internet il y aura des trucs
il
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières